[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEREN GIANNINI: Welcome.
Welcome to Container,
Serveless Anywhere.
I'm Steren Giannini, a product
manager on the serverless team
at Google Cloud.
RYAN GREGG: Hi.
I'm Ryan Gregg.
I'm also a product manager
on the serverless team.
The cat's out of the bag.
We can say that it's about
Cloud Run now, right?
STEREN GIANNINI:
We can say it now.
RYAN GREGG: Hopefully,
you're in the right place.
If you came to learn about
Cloud Run, this is it.
But let's give you a
little bit of background
before we start on that.
So for over 10 years,
Google has been
investing in the
developer experience
for running on the cloud.
Our very first product
for Google Cloud,
actually before it
was Google Cloud,
was App Engine, which was
invented before the word
serverless was even a thing.
It allowed developers
to write code and run it
at scale in the cloud
without the need
to worry about infrastructure.
Since then we've also
released Cloud Functions,
which is a-- excuse
me-- functions
as a service-based product.
And these two together
have allowed developers
to understand the benefits
of serverless compute,
allowing them to
focus on their code,
and not worry about
the infrastructure that
is necessary to run that code.
Our customers, probably
all of you here today,
or many of you here today,
have been very successful
using these platforms
to run your business,
and recognizing the value
that App Engine and Cloud
Functions provide
their engineering teams
on lowering the requirements
of running production code.
We've even heard people
say, Google is my SRE.
I don't have to worry about
having that role in my company.
But serverless wasn't always
accessible to everybody.
There were restrictions
and limitations
on using our serverless
platforms that caused problems.
And we often heard
from customers things
like I have these
existing binaries that I
want to be able
to use, or there's
a particular coding language
that is optimal for the task
that I'm using.
When is that going
to be supported?
Or even Java developers maybe.
Python developers
probably remember.
Maybe it wasn't even
the whole language
that was available in
the serverless platform.
It was just a subset of it.
So there were challenges.
And we wanted to make this more
accessible to everybody, not
just the people who could
fit the mold that we had.
But what is serverless?
How do we think of it as Google?
After all of the years of
running App Engine and Cloud
Functions, all of the
feedback from customers,
we've developed a model for
how we think about serverless.
And it divides into two pieces.
One is the operational model.
This is the sort of way
that serverless runs.
It's the idea that you
don't have to worry
about the infrastructure.
There's no servers to
provision, no operating systems
to install, none of the
sort of details of how
things work at that level.
It's also about
managed security.
So ensuring that
Google takes care
of the details on how to secure
your production environment.
And then a really important
piece for many of you
is pay as you go, or
pay only for usage.
The idea that you aren't
paying for provisioned servers
or provisioned nodes, but
only the compute that you're
actually using.
And there's a programming
model aspect to this as well.
So this is the
developer experience.
It's moving from being
a traditional model
to being more
service-based, being
able to have managed
services that you leverage
to get your work done
instead of bringing out
your own dependencies or even
writing those things yourself.
It's about being event-driven.
So instead of building
monolithic applications that
are focused on the
application, think about
how the data flows
through your system,
and how you can attach
compute to the events that
are generated by that.
And then there's a third
piece that we think it truly
means to be a
serverless at Google,
and that is about being open.
It's really the ideal of
what serverless should be,
not so much what serverless
has been in the past.
So we want to make
sure that the developer
experience is idiomatic.
It feels natural to
you as a developer.
You're not constrained by what
the platform has to offer.
And also that it
should be portable.
You don't want to be locked into
a particular platform vendor
when you're using a
serverless technology.
You should be able to run it
wherever it makes the most
sense for your business
and change your mind later
on if you want to.
This is the true
value of serverless,
all of these things.
So that you can just
focus on writing the code
that matters, the core
value of your business,
and not have to worry about
all the other details.
Separately, though, from
serverless happening,
there's been another
trend in the industry;
the rise of containers.
Containers over the
last four or five years
have really picked up.
This is a Google Trends graph
showing like peak interest
at the top, at 100.
You can see we're at the current
peak interest for containers.
Containers, if you
don't what they are,
are a way to easily
move code and binaries
between environments.
So you've got the confidence
that the way that application
runs in one environment will
carry over to the next place
that you run it.
So you're going to have a
CICD system produce containers
for you, validate
that they work,
and then literally take the
same code, the same binaries,
the same container package
and run it in production,
and get all the same experience.
In fact, it's become
such a great experience
for developers and operators
alike that it is now
an industry standard with a
ton of tooling and support
and an entire ecosystem
around how you build and use
containers.
And while you can containerize
just about anything
and the tools make this really
easy, running containers,
eh, not always so easy.
There's orchestration platforms
that you need to deal with.
There's Kubernetes.
There's all of the APIs
and lifecycle management
that go into that.
You have to think about how
to scale your application,
how to get the most out of
it with all of the stuff.
It really means that you
need an operator running--
sitting there with
your code to make sure
that it's running
correctly in production.
But Steren, what if there was a
way to do all of this greatness
with containers and get all
the benefits out of this
without the need
for an operator?
What if developers could
do it on their own?
STEREN GIANNINI: I wonder,
what if it could be easier?
You know what?
Let's switch to the demo screen.
What if I could
simply from the Cloud
console open the
Cloud Run section?
What if I could click a button?
The deployment form opens, and
paste the URL of a container
image that I have
stored previously
in my container registry.
And then without
doing anything else,
without provisioning any
infrastructure, click Create.
That's it.
That's all we need to deploy
a container to Cloud Run.
No infrastructure to
provision in advance.
No cluster creation.
No Yammer file.
And boom, we have it.
I literally did not have the
time to finish my sentence.
But Cloud Run has imported
our container, made sure
that it started, and gave us
back a stable and secured HTTPS
endpoint to invoke a container.
Let's open it.
It's running.
That's it.
It's that simple to deploy
an existing container
image to Cloud Run.
So yes, we are introducing at
Google Next 2019 Cloud Run,
bringing serverless
to containers.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
But you might wonder, what
can I do with Cloud Run?
Well, although the use
cases are very broad,
Cloud Run allows you to deploy
any stateless HTTP container.
So that means that any HTTP
request-driven workload
or workload that you can
invoke asynchronously
will be a good
fit for Cloud Run.
This kind of platform allows
a wide variety of use cases.
Let's take a look
at some of them.
We can find two categories.
The first one is what
we call public services.
They would be you want to host
a website automatically scaled
to handle the incoming traffic.
Cloud Run is great for that.
If you want to expose an
API endpoint, the same.
The back end for your
mobile app, Cloud Run.
Or maybe a simple
web hook that you
use to receive a GitHub
notification or maybe
a chat bot.
This is also a good use case.
Everything that is
automatically scaled
to handle the incoming
traffic that varies over time.
Then there is a second
category of services;
those who are not
exposed to the internet.
Those ones are, for example,
if you are breaking out
the monolith of
your application,
you might have created
many microservices.
Well, what if each of
those microservices
could scale
independently on demand
to meet the load that
is needed from them?
So private
microservices are also
a good fit; things that are
not exposed to the internet,
but that are part of your
overall cloud architecture.
And lastly, as I
mentioned, you can
take those private services,
but instead of invoking them
directly via HTTP,
you can use things
like Web Server or Cloud
Tasks to do asynchronous task
execution where the task is
executed on an on demand Cloud
Run service.
So some of our alpha testers
have built many such use cases
for doing image transformation,
video processing, document
processing.
All of this is feasible
with Cloud Run.
So over this talk, we
are going to go over
the three main pillars
of the Cloud Run product.
We will see how it
takes containers,
and how it deploys
them very fast.
We will explain a bit what are
the benefits of containers.
We will show you how this is
a natively serverless product.
And lastly, you
will see that you
can have the same Cloud
Run experience wherever
you want it.
So let's get started.
Containers to
production in seconds.
This is the first
pillar of Cloud Run.
So yes, Cloud Run
runs containers.
But why containers?
Well, first off, they allow
you to run any programming
language.
So you're not restricted anymore
by the five or seven languages
that Google Cloud provides.
No, no, no.
Any language you want,
you can bring in.
I brought a shell
script into Cloud Run,
if that is even a language.
But really anything.
We've got [INAUDIBLE].
We've got Rest.
You can try that.
Along with your favorite
programming language,
you can also use your favorite
library from this language,
but also from the operating
system, because containers also
capture the OS packages that
you want inside your container.
And more interestingly,
any software, any binary
can also go into your container.
And so this unlocks some
very interesting use cases
where it's not only
about source code.
It's about executing
software in a serverless way.
Containers have a very
large ecosystem around them.
For example, you will find
many, many official base images
on Docker Hub that are
officially maintained
by the language maintainers.
And we have to acknowledge that
today containers have become
an industry standard
for packaging,
distributing, testing,
and deploying software.
They are really, in my opinion,
better than a zip file.
So let me welcome
Thomas from Airbus,
who has been part of the
Cloud Run alpha program
for some months.
He's going to tell you how
he has been using Cloud Run.
[APPLAUSE]
THOMAS BONFORT:
I'm Thomas Bonfort.
I'm a cloud architect
and a software engineer
in Airbus Defense and Space.
Aside from flying airplanes,
as you probably already know,
we also have several
constellations
of optical and radar
satellites that we launch,
operate, and provide services
around the data that's
produced from these sensors.
So let's talk about
serverless computing.
As you can see from these
vintage photos, our use of IT
goes quite far back.
We have actually more than
30 years of experience
in storing, processing, and
distributing digital satellite
imagery.
The nature of these
several year long programs
when launching a
spacecraft obviously amount
to quite a large amount
of stable and legacy code
and infrastructure.
But what we started our
move to public cloud
platforms a few years ago.
In that perspective,
I was very excited
when Steren proposed
us to be part
of the alpha tester program for
Cloud Run to experiment ways
in which we could shift
our usage of compute power
for this use case.
As part of our move
to cloud platforms,
we recently opened the
OneAtlas digital platform
to provide data use API
access to tasking satellites
to acquire imagery when
specific conditions are met,
and the time when those weather
conditions are recurrent.
We provide also download
and viewing access
to raw and processed imagery.
And we also provide extract
analytics from these raw data
and provide insights such as
vehicle and infrastructure
detection, change monitoring,
precision agriculture,
or deforestation monitoring.
Now, fueling this
platform actually
requires ingesting thousands
of images every day.
Each one of those
images is composed
of several billions of
pixels, and weighing
in at several gigabytes
of raw compressed data.
Under the scenes this leads
to quite a few challenges.
We want to minimize
storage size,
and we want to efficiently
respond to undermined access
to provide services
without overprovisioning
compute instances.
So let's explore a scenario
where Cloud Run can help us
with that.
For this use case, we'll be
transforming our raw imagery
into the growing
industry standard that's
called the Cloud-Optimized
GeoTIFFs, which is just
a standard TIFF file, but where
all the imagery and metadata
and the pixel indexes
have been stored
at the beginning of the file
to be compatible with object
storage Get Range requests.
So our first step
is a batch process
which will ingest
our raw imagery
and transform it into these
Cloud-Optimized GeoTIFF files
into a cloud storage bucket.
Jobs like these will be
continuously launched whenever
a new image becomes available.
So now in the second
phase in order
to be able to service
requests to clients
who want to only access
parts of the imagery,
we can deploy
Cloud Run services,
which are just local images that
contain any low level code that
will be able to
access and transform
the raw pixel data
from the GeoTIFF files,
and to fit the needs of
analytics jobs, machine
learning, training,
and inference jobs,
or just interactive viewing.
So why is Cloud Run a great
fit for this use case?
Being able to run custom
code on the serving instances
allows us to store the data
only once in a private format
while still offering the
full range of services
at request time.
And this lowers
recurring storage costs
by avoiding duplication of data.
We also take advantage of the
scaling down to zero instances
to be able to deploy as
many services as we need.
And the scaling up
of the instances
also ensures us that our
services are available and will
absorb any usage likes.
Now, in situations where using
public cloud isn't feasible,
the Knative roots that
Cloud Run is built upon
will allow for code reuse
and shield us from lock in.
So yeah, all in all, we
are excited to continue
exploring use cases that can
be unlocked by Cloud Run.
And we just can't wait for
it to be available in Europe.
STEREN GIANNINI: It's coming.
Thanks, Thomas.
Thanks a lot for being
a part of the alpha
and for the tremendous
feedback you've provided.
It's great to see how
you are leveraging
the power of containers
to run your own binary
in the free auto scale
environment that is Cloud Run.
OK.
So let's go a bit about
how we get to a container.
Maybe that's of use
for some of you,
but let's just go over this.
The first thing is to
actually code your service.
On Cloud Run, we have
a few requirements
for you, not a lot, but
very important ones.
So we call that the
container runtime contract.
Any container that
meets those requirements
will be able to be deployed
in auto scale on Cloud Run.
The first one is that the
request and the Pub/Sub events
and any other
asynchronous task are
going to be delivered to your
container via the HTTP protocol
on a given port.
So from your side
as a developer,
you have listen for HTTP
requests on that port.
You know how to do that, right?
The other very important
point is that your container
should not rely on local state.
Of course, you can use
persistent storage,
like databases and blob storage.
But inside a container, you can
only rely on temporary states.
The things that you create,
because of the nature
of the autoscaling of
Cloud Run, will not
be here necessarily the next
time we invoke your container.
And so to store a
state, of course,
Google Cloud has many options.
Filestore, Cloud
Storage, BigQuery.
So once you've built your app
that meets those requirements,
you can package it up
into a container image.
So we call that the build phase.
So it's literally we take all
of those files, run a command,
and end up with a
container image.
To do that, the obvious tool
that everybody knows about
is Docker.
Docker Build,
Docker Push, this is
what will transform your local
source into a container image
and push it to the
Container Registry.
The Google Cloud has
another product for you.
That is Cloud Build.
And Cloud Build
allows you to do just
that, build your container,
except that this time,
it is doing it in the cloud.
So you don't even need to have
the tooling installed locally.
And once again, like
any serverless product,
you pay per usage.
So when you don't
build, you don't pay.
And you just pay for
the time of your builds.
So Cloud Build can
build local containers,
can do even more complex
builds, and can also
help you automatically
deploy your container
image to Cloud Run.
And lastly, we should
mention that containers
are a very good fit with
continuous integration
and continuous delivery.
For example, you will build
your container once, test it
locally, test it on your
continuous testing system,
push it to staging, making
sure that everything
is good on staging, and then
take that exact same container
and deploy to production.
The container stays the same,
because that's very important.
The thing that you tested
is actually the thing
that goes into production.
So containers are a
very good tool for that.
And as I said,
Cloud Build can help
you achieve the
continuous integration
and continuous delivery.
But of course, you
can use whatever tool
you want to do that.
And the last step
is to run things.
So here we go from one container
image in Google Cloud Container
Registry, and with
one simple command
or one click of a button,
we deploy that to Cloud Run.
On Cloud Run, as
you've seen, you
get a stable and secured
HTTPS URL that you can decide
or not to expose
to the internet.
And this happens, as you've
seen, in just a few seconds.
So the demo idea was really
a hello world container.
I want to go over those
steps with a real use case.
Let's switch to the
demo screen, please.
Yes.
OK.
So what I have here is
just a bit of Python code
that is listening for
incoming HTTP requests.
And then it's
invoking OpenOffice,
because what Microsoft is doing
is it's converting Microsoft
Word documents into PDFs.
And to do that we just call
LibreOffice to get it together
as a PDF.
There is another very important
file in my web service here.
As you might know,
it's named Docker file.
If you don't know
this, don't be scared.
It's super simple.
Let's take a look, like
literally 16 lines.
The first line is me using
what we call a base image.
The base image will
contain already
all of the packages and tools
to run that particular language.
In our case, it's the
official Python base image
maintained by the
Python community,
or maybe even the
Python maintainer.
We also have a line where
we install OpenOffice,
because as you remember,
we invoked OpenOffice.
So we first have to install it
from the regular Alpine package
manager.
And the last step is to
specify your start command.
That's what we have to do.
Start command, that is how
to actually start our code.
So as you remember,
the next step
is to build that into
a container image.
I could use any tool.
But I'm going to use Cloud
Build, gcloud build submit.
I give you the tag.
And here I directly point to
a Google container registery.
Oh, there is a typo.
Submit.
OK.
So what's happening here, GCloud
is uploading my local source,
and then triggering a remote
build using Cloud Build.
Because OpenOffice is quite
a big software, quite old,
it's probably in Java.
It has a lot of dependencies.
Because of all of that, it can
take maybe up to two or three
minutes to build.
So I will spare you this.
I actually built
it before the demo.
So let's go to the next step.
The next step is to
deploy that to Cloud Run.
You have seen the Cloud Console
UI, where you can simply
open a form and deploy.
Here I'm going to use
the command line, which
is gcloud beta, because we are
still in beta, run, deploy.
Then I pass an image.
So as I told you, it's in
Google Cloud Container Registry.
Run-intro is our product name.
And the image that I built
before is PDF-Service.
Let's hit Enter.
Without more
configuration, GCloud
is going to ask me, where
do you want to deploy?
And yes, Thomas, today it's only
US Central 1, but stay tuned.
The other regions are coming.
And it's suggesting
for me a service name.
Well, sounds good.
And it's asking me,
do I want to allow
unauthenticated
invocation to my service?
This means, do I allow anybody
to invoke that service?
And for the sake
of the demo, I'm
going to say yes to show
it to you in my browser.
Right here, same as
before, Cloud Run
is importing your
container image.
It's creating a
revision under the hood.
Right now it's performing
a health check.
So that means it's making
sure that my container can
start and listen on
the appropriate port.
You remember it listens for
HTTP requests on the port,
on the given port.
And we are done.
We get-- let me zoom
out a little bit.
We get a stable URL under HTTPS.
Let's open it.
OK.
So this microservice
converts DOCs to PDFs.
Let's give it to a DOC.
Upload it.
So here my DOC is uploaded
to my cloud service.
Under the hood, Cloud Run
is invoking OpenOffice
to convert that DOC into a PDF.
And we get back a PDF.
So this is the PDF that
I got back from Chrome--
from Cloud Run.
And I view it in Chrome.
So that's it.
Importantly here, I only had
to pay when my service was
actually processing my request.
Right now it's scaled to zero.
I don't pay anything.
It's only when I send a document
and when I process a document
that I actually am charged
for the resource I'm using
during that processing time.
Now I will hand it over to Ryan.
And can we switch
back to the slides
to tell you about how
this is serverless.
RYAN GREGG: I'm back.
So that was a really
cool demo of how easy
it is to take a container,
actually even take Python code,
build it into a container,
deploy it using--
I don't want to call it old.
I'll call it legacy--
vintage software
STEREN GIANNINI: Vintage.
RYAN GREGG: That's now
running serverless.
But what does it mean
by natively serverless?
How do we think
about how serverless
and the principles
that I defined earlier
apply to Cloud Run?
So first of all,
in the old world,
if you were doing this on,
say, Compute Engine or even
Kubernetes Engine, you would
have to provision servers.
You'd have to think about
how to scale your workload,
and how many servers you might
need to be able to transform
thousands of PDFs on demand.
And really, what
that would mean is
that you would have
to overprovision
the number of servers that
you bought, because you wanted
to make sure that there was
enough capacity to handle all
of the load that was coming in.
The great thing
about Cloud Run is
that you get to do all
of that without having
to worry about any of it.
Google takes care of it for you.
So you as a developer
can just focus
on the code that
matters, and let Google
run all of the infrastructure.
We give you a URL.
We automatically
provision TLS certificates
to give you a secure end point.
We take care of the redundancy
and the automatic failover.
We make sure that
everything keeps
working so that
your application can
scale with you as more and more
users start using your service.
And as Steren said,
it's all pay for use.
So what does that
really look like?
This is really simple, right?
When you have no
requests, there's
no instance of your
application running.
The container is put to sleep.
Later, when a request
comes in, we'll
quickly spin up that
instance of the container
and start serving
traffic out of it.
And Cloud Run
supports concurrency,
so we can serve
multiple requests out
of that same container.
As more load happens,
we'll create more instances
of that container to handle
the load appropriately
to keep the latency low.
And then as the requests
start to trail off,
we'll spin down instances
of that container.
So you don't have to
keep paying for them.
Actually, you don't have
to pay for them anyway.
What does that
look like, though,
on the monetary side, Steren?
STEREN GIANNINI: Well, because
of these autoscaling mechanism,
we are able to give you a pay
per use billing [INAUDIBLE]..
So that literally
means that you are only
paying for the resources
that your service is using.
In practice, that means paying
for exact CPU, exact memory,
and number of requests
performed during the processing
of those requests down to an
increment of 100 milliseconds.
Once the request is out, this
is zero on your bill for you.
And so as Ryan said,
Cloud Run scales up.
So we wanted to show
that to you on our demo.
So let's switch to
the demo screen.
What we have here is
a load testing tool
that we send many requests
to or the container
that we just deployed.
So you remember
our container is--
OK.
Our container is
processing PDFs.
So you remember that a PDF
processing time is not instant.
It takes a few seconds
to download the PDF
and then transform it.
Download the DOC and
transform it into a PDF
by invoking OpenOffice.
So what you see here, I
asked the load testing tool
to transform 1,000
PDFs in one minute.
And here what you see is the
scale up of Cloud Run, which
OpenOffice being a
quite big software,
it takes some time to load.
So that's why we see
some higher latency.
And then so here we have
processed maybe 500 documents
in roughly 30 seconds.
And overall, the
latency, OpenOffice
takes 10 seconds to start
and process the PDFs.
Going forward, this time will go
down, because once a request--
once a document
has been processed,
Cloud Run is able to reuse
the run instance in order
to process the next one.
So of course, the
latency of the startup
will take a bit more time.
But once Cloud Run has
many run instances for you,
over time things
will settle down.
And here we process
the 900 Word documents
that we are stored in Google
Cloud Storage in a minute.
So if you're interested
in scaling performances,
Jason in his breakout session
went up to 10,000 instances
with his Cloud Run service.
However, here I just showed
you sending some load
on a real use case, which
is processing documents,
which takes many seconds.
So that's why we haven't
seen that much high scaling.
But overall, 1,000 PDFs in
one minute is quite good.
RYAN GREGG: It's
pretty cool that you
took a 2 gigabyte
container with OpenOffice
and ran it serverless.
STEREN GIANNINI: The
container is literally 2 gigs.
And we looked at it.
RYAN GREGG: So if we could
switch back to the slides.
So that was a good demo about
how Cloud Run can autoscale.
The third pillar of Cloud
Run is one experience
where you want it, which is all
about portability and openness.
That last pillar
of the developer
experience that I
introduced at the beginning.
And portability probably
means different things
to different people in the room.
So it might mean being able
to take your workload that you
started on-prem and being
able to move it to the cloud.
Or it could be about portability
of your own understandings
and experiences as a developer.
The great thing
about Cloud Run is
that we wanted to make
sure that we satisfied
both of those constraints.
We wanted to make sure
that if a developer had
to learn something new to use
this platform, that it could
be reused on every project they
would work on in the future,
that those skills could
transfer again and again.
And Cloud Run has
a great promise.
But I'm going to take
a side note here,
because I've talked
about containers.
And I've talked
about portability.
And if you know
Google at all, you're
probably thinking, like,
hey, what about Kubernetes?
What about Kubernetes Engine?
That's what I think
of when I think
of containers and portability.
And you'd be right.
Kubernetes is a very
portable platform
that supports running
containers really well today.
However, Kubernetes is really
fantastic for the operator,
but doesn't do a whole
lot for the developer.
You still have to think about
how to scale your application
and how to do the
network programming,
how to manage all of the details
of how your container will
run on Kubernetes.
And as Kelsey said, Kubernetes
is a great starting place.
It's a great platform for
building other platforms.
It's not the end game.
This is where
Cloud Run comes in.
Cloud Run and its component,
or its sister component,
Cloud Run on GKE, provides a
serverless experience anywhere
that you need it to be.
So like the Cloud
Run managed service
that Steren was showing
you, Cloud Run on GKE
gives you many of
the same benefits.
The same flexibility
and the control
to run a container,
any container,
on your Kubernetes cluster.
You get the same
autoscaling benefits,
including scaling to zero.
You can even take advantage
of GKE specific features.
So you can use
custom machine types.
You can ask for incredibly
high amounts of memory.
You can use hardware
accelerators,
like GPUs and TPUs.
And you can have access
to the VPC networking.
All of this lets
you use the benefits
of Cloud Run on your existing
Kubernetes investment.
So you can be fully serverless
and run on a regular house--
excuse me-- the regular
fully managed Cloud Run.
Or you can have that same
developer experience,
the same tooling, the
same API, and run it
inside your Kubernetes Engine
Cluster with Cloud Run on GKE.
And now to tell you
about why this truly
matters to our
customers, I'd like
to invite Guillaume from
Birdz up to the stage
to tell you about his use case.
[APPLAUSE]
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
Hello, everybody.
I'm Guillaume Blaquiere.
I'm the data delivery
team leader at Birdz.
And Birdz is a branch
company of Veolia.
Veolia is a major
French company.
We have 170,000 employees
over 50 countries.
The core businesses of Veolia
are water, waste, and energy.
Birdz, it's the branch
company of Veolia.
It specializes in IoT,
which designs devices.
I have to deploy and
configure devices on field.
We process the data.
We store them, and we divert
services to our customer.
And all of this works on a
local network with our legacy
protocol, but we also have the
new ones, like Sigfox, Lorawan,
and NB-IoT.
The main business of Birdz
are smart water meters,
which represents
90% of our assets
on fields with devices
designed to live up
to 15 years on lithium battery.
These devices have to
be deployed on feed
by a plumber with
special training
to plug and to
configure the devices.
These steps take times,
and thus takes money,
because a small [INAUDIBLE]
is more than 10,000 water
meters to deploy.
That's why our
customers don't want
to deploy devices
on each contract,
and want to reuse Birdz
devices all the life long.
Even if it's not Birdz
or Veolia as contractor.
And thus they also want to
decode the Birdz messages
on the home at the end of the
contract with Birdz or Veolia.
That's why we
designed this solution
where an IoT operator sends
us messages through Webhook.
We push them to a pub/sub to
absorb some peak of charge.
Pub/sub pushes the
messages to the decoder
to duplicate, decode,
and valorize the data,
and store them into bitcoin.
[INAUDIBLE] a scheduler
triggers a container
to extract the data
from bitcoin and to load
them-- to load it in
the database for serving
our websites.
The customer wants to post
and to process the decoding
by themselves, and to
have the capability
to deploy on the
cluster with Knative.
This part, it could be on
GCP, or on the cloud provider,
or even on-premise.
With GCP, we have two solutions
to deploy our container.
And therefore, the
message acquisition
is quite simple, because it's
independent, simple, and light.
And we have to absorb
some peak of charge.
That's why we
choose to deploy it
on the fully managed solution.
On the other hand,
the message processing
has to access on-prem
data through a VPN,
and just through a VPC.
And the custom VPC are
not yet implemented
in a free manager solution.
And we have to deploy it on GKE.
Morever, this decoding part has
to access stateful resources,
like a [INAUDIBLE]
or persistent volume.
That's why GKE is the best case.
The third part, the
data preparation
is quite difficult to choose.
Indeed, it's an infrequent
call, and it can be quick.
It's just few data
and few customers,
but it can be too long for
the fully-managed solution.
It is a [INAUDIBLE]
of customers.
To date, it's not a problem,
because with the same code,
the same container, the same
UI, or the same common name,
if you want, it's really easy
to move from one solution
to another one.
You only need to specify or not
the cluster and the solution
is deployed on--
one solution or the other one.
It's very easy and really good.
Thanks, Steren and
Ryan, for that.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN GREGG: Thank you.
Thank you for that great use of
Cloud Run and Cloud Run on GKE,
and really showing how the
portability of that experience
is important for you.
I'm going to do a quick
demo of how this works just
to prove that everything
that we said is true.
So if we could switch
back to the demo machine.
We're back here in Cloud Console
in Steren's demo project.
And I'm going to just create
that same service that we
watched Steren deploy before.
So I'll do
gcr.io/run-intro/pdf-service.
And this time, instead
of deploying it
into the fully
managed service, I'm
going to choose from
the location dropdown
this highly available
Kubernetes cluster that I've
created before.
And I'll pick the
default namespace.
And I'll just click Create.
And so just like before with
Cloud Run fully managed,
now Cloud Run on GKE is
deploying the service,
bringing in the container,
creating a URL for me,
and making everything work.
And so now this is
actually running
on my Kubernetes instance.
So if I click on
this URL, you'll
see here's the same application.
It says running on
Cloud Run on GKE,
just in case you
didn't believe me.
And then we can switch
back and actually
look at the Kubernetes UI.
And I'll show you again.
If we go to workloads,
for example,
you can see down here the
PDF service has been deployed
onto this Kubernetes cluster.
And if I switch
over to services--
and for those of you who are
unfamiliar in Kubernetes land,
services are about networking,
not about services--
you'll see the PDF service
here with both an external name
and a cluster IP address.
So this service that I created,
or that Steren created earlier
is now running inside
my Kubernetes cluster
using the same API, the same
UI, the same experience.
I didn't have to
change anything.
But I could easily
deploy it into Kubernetes
or into manage serverless.
If we could switch
back to the slides.
Thanks.
So we have shared tooling.
We also have a CLI.
Instead of specifying the region
that you want to deploy into,
you specify the cluster name
that you want to deploy.
It's very simple.
But how do we do all this?
We could have done it in a
number of different ways.
But we did this based on
the Knative Project, which
is an open source project
for serverless building
blocks on Kubernetes that we
launched last year at Next,
about eight months ago.
And it provides the common API,
the common runtime contract,
and a reference implementation
for how to do everything
that we've shown here today.
It implements
learnings from Google
and has more than 50
different companies
who have contributed
into the project.
So it's really taking
this standard approach
to how to run services
workloads on top of Kubernetes.
And it provides this
portable experience
between both of the managed
services that we offer on GCP,
as well as being able to take it
anywhere that Kubernetes runs.
You can deploy Knative onto
that Kubernetes cluster
and have the same tooling,
the same API, and everything
working there.
In fact, at the developer
keynote tomorrow
night, Steren and
I will show you
how we can even deploy that
onto an IBM cluster running
Manage Knative that really
emphasizes that portability.
And you can learn more
by going to knative.dev.
[MUSIC PLAYING]